welcome to this video this is the
highlights video for round 11 of the
candidates tournament in kuntum on disk
Siberia Russia and the 11th round means
there's only four hours to go before the
round former world champion vision I was
leading the tournament with plus three
score head of levon aronian with the
plus one score so one point behind but
vicious a better tie break and some
players on fifty percent so if if the
other players want to have a chance to
catch on and they need to get Winston so
let's see what happened today are not
having crucial game him that's black
against kramnik this is the first game
I'm going to look at and we got a
Catalan opening not a big surprise the
Catalans been aligned in chrome legs
repertoire for a number of years so it
could easily be expected by holland and
term we got this line the classical
maybe the main line of the catalan the
black first developed this King side and
then captures on c4 yeah here White has
two ways to try to retrieve the pawn
most popular is Quincy to very often
played by Crom League or alternatively
Q&A for most leading to the same
position like that this has been debated
already a couple of times between both
players this time I ever chrome neck
goes for Knight e5 a move that is of
course also well known and that he has
played term before as well most notably
in the candidates tournament last year
against cards in a very crucial game on
the best reply for black now is the move
knight c6 that could come as a surprise
to some people don't know the line it is
in fact the best move forcing a direct
decision and it involves the pawn
sacrifice
um the reason why this is the best move
is that what others simply don't are not
active enough if black plays something
like c5 he'll end up in a symmetrical
porn structure position where this
Bishop is so far better than the c8
bishop that black can never really
equalize 96 as mentioned involves the
pawn sacrifice because white can play
just like ramnik did check and here it's
not a pawn sacrifice yet but the c-4
porn is pretty much doomed black will
lose this pawn and we'll need to show
compensation for the material deficit
here kramnik played the move Knight to
a3 which is almost the novelty only two
games played in earlier examples he had
played Quincy to against Carlton this is
also had been a new idea at the time all
night a three here and we see that after
c 5s and the capture of the queen there
should be three black has a hard time to
keep the poorness mentioned we are
called we are talking about a pawn
sacrifice essentially with this knight
c6 move yeah here the queen is detect
and it has no way to protect the pawn
something like that is simply delaying
the capture like is going to h5 this is
the best move I think it prevents this
for the time being because this leads to
excellent play for black damaging
White's pawn structure in normal sleep
um white needs to prepare the capture
with f3 and the pawn as mentioned is
doomed anyway and now on plays very
strong place c3 best move in the
position returning the porn while
damaging the pawn structure and also
with Queen a five via text the night
which is now not protected anymore by
the b2 pawn and this is the main problem
why its position is somewhat loose this
night is loose the bishop is loose and
the pawn is a week and it turned out
that our
these moves like always has this idea to
capture and play Queen a six to gain the
the piece back and white basically has
no way to keep the material Cromley took
on a seven and after Bishop c4 90s Queen
a seven check Queenie 30 this was forced
now the point of all that Queen asics
attacking this night twice it needs to
move and after Luke see two black is
counter-attacking two pawns and white
will lose upon back a couple of moves
later they had traded even more pieces
and yeah exactly here agreed to a draw
yeah um a very clean game I think by
both players Kramnik tried this this
idea that he see mentioned in the press
conference had in store for a number of
years and that he well remembered just
briefly before he decided to play the
Catalan but when he had it on the body
actually noticed that the whole idea
against best play is not promising all
that much and exactly this best place
what are not found over the board so
he's really in good shape it's not like
this is an idea that can can knock you
off easily or something but as it is so
so so great so complicated and so on
it's certainly manageable to to diffuse
it over the board but what she is doing
it and only am i can only am admires
form in this in this event really a
really flawless performance I think yeah
I draw him and which is very much good
enough for him to keep cruising with
this with this lead in the tournament
okay next game to look at Sevilla aronia
and two of two of the guys who actually
still have a chance and let's see what
their plate this will replace the Y an
idea 3g three this is not really a name
yet it's it's turning into a red team
interior took on d5 this already had
been played in the last year's
candidates by kramnik with wide against
aronia so we follow this game below is
obviously content with this type of
position which I actually know from my
own games and they're always some yeah I
don't like it so much to be honest for
why do our finger think it's very am
very tedious structure I mean it's
completely symmetrical in the center you
have the bishops but they don't they do
they don't do that much this Bishop is
looking into a pawn this is looking at a
pawn so this is a position that can only
be very slowly open to my white very am
it's a very slow play and now I thought
that black should be fine in this
structure yeah we had some more moves
like improving his pieces night to d6
and now knight to e7 this is a very neat
set up this is basically preparing for
white playing g4 at some stage like here
for example after which black has a very
nice blockade of the isolated pawn will
return to a good square and tens no
problems before it's one of the ideas
that writes the rest of the position but
slowly I went another way he activated
this night and then pushed on the
queenside yay Aronian is putting up a
very precise defense up to a point and
exactly here after Bishop e7 it's the
only point really in this game where
there is some something thats Villa
could have done here for was an
interesting tribe which he didn't go for
the the main line after this or the
critical line is the move b6 which seems
to be not good for black but it's very
difficult to to figure out what you can
actually take on d5 which is a very
strong move it is
as usual quickly pointed out by the
computer but for human it is tricky I
think a human would consider the move
but after this it's a full piece of
sacrifice and now capturing here I
believe if you I don't I didn't see the
press conference let me start this way
so I don't know why svidler discarded
the e4 idea it's possible that he came
to this position and maybe thought okay
I might have compensation here but the
computer turn points out that this
position is actually very very good form
for white it's a very difficult for
black to to find the defense here white
has this threat which is quite huge so
if points and black retreats yeah sure
p.m. how do you how do you keep the
night now it's very difficult to see how
let's say here okay okay I'm taking and
playing Bishop d5 and just win it's very
very hard to defend the position the
computer is actually giving it as a very
large advantage so it seems that b6 is
not really good after you form so
aronian would have needed to take here
probably and we would have get gotten to
a position of that type where white at
least has the two bishops in a position
that is opening up and as some and not
not like in in this close structure with
a pawn on e3 and everything's is is
closed and the bishops don't have much
scope so there's some chance here that
he certainly what he could have tried I
guess in the complications after v6 he
didn't he didn't really yeah look at
this um so deep as the computer is able
to do okay queen bee one was played and
after 97 the pressure on c5 is so big
that you need to allow exchanges and do
with them yeah a couple of moves later
we had one pair of nights exchange and
now queens traded here they actually
already agreed to a draw yeah after this
White has the two bishops okay but
there's no way you're really going to
make any headway here black can set up a
fortress-like position with let's say 96
and f5 and white is never going to open
the position it's just too symmetrical
so well maybe there was a slight chance
for swidler hear you you never know with
what I ronnian is playing if he goes
e-form maybe yet played b6 you don't
know um yeah but a draw so both don't
really catch up to two honored okay next
game are Drake in marbella off on my
radiographers on fifty percent so as one
of the guys who has still has a minimum
chance to catch island however in this
game they're relatively quickly set up a
Catalan in position where now and dragon
took on c5 which is a quite a
conservative choice it allows a queen
trade this was played and now c3 like is
giving the porn back to somewhat worsen
White's pawn structure this is a
well-known line which is believed to be
between a slight edge for wide and
equality and we see that under aching is
getting some activity but mamedyarov
look at the clock he's playing all this
out of his preparation he absolutely
knows what he's doing and after at this
he played the move a five this is quite
strong why does now faced with a
concrete idea if he plays nothing then
there's a form night moves may be here
and night to a five and this is the
target now and it's not very nice for
white you don't really want dad this is
why and drinking plate a for just
stopping this all together and now after
Bishop e8 we have got a trade and here
it's actually quite interesting position
Y term needs to think about the Queen
side
if you play it very slowly and don't do
much it might happen that you get
blockade forget this pawns located for
instance a 394 if you now doing nothing
move again let's say something like that
there is this idea and black might be
able to fix both pawns and actually play
against those this is probably not too
great it's more likely to be better for
black so white went with a 5 ever see 5
sorry and took a five now and well this
is just very draw now because white will
go no matter what Blake does go here and
we have a trade the sea porn for the
beep on and it turns out that after a
couple of news check we have even looks
traded and now we have an end game with
pure bishop pair against bishop and
night which should theoretically flavor
white and certainly it does here but the
symmetrical pawn structure without black
having any serious weakness points out
that this will be a draw they played
this on for a while or let's say on
Drake and it's because he's the one with
the bishops and the the ideas at least
so try to advance a bit but it's simply
too symmetrical like it's just defending
all the pawns and stays put yeah him
with some tactics I even we got the
complete trade down surfer of all pieces
and this is just a very easy draw with
the King always blocking the G porn so
pretty much pretty much eventless game
which is somewhat due to the opening
where after this white was basically
forced to wrap the game up with c5
otherwise you would be worse so yeah
nothing great happening here for mommy
geography I think it would have needed a
win to have any sort of chance but okay
it's a it's just just to draw this game
okay to Palo kayaking kayaking also on
fifty percent while took part of his own
minus two and completely out of it
kayaking
some slight chances because it still
plays wish you with white but still he
needs to win other another game to
really catch up let's see what happened
to him we got to an English double
fianchetto with b6 and g6 or this has
been played a number of times ok now
we're g4 was played an interesting move
that tries to push the night away we got
to an interesting position why this term
has transferred its night over to g3
getting this dreaded and this has led to
an interesting pawn structure with white
having GG pawns and this G pollen g5 is
a boy it's a bit of an annoyance it
keeps this square under control some
night f6 is not possible and it yeah
secures wide space advantage yeah
kayaking is playing this Queen a8
maneuver pretty typical setting up
pressure on the long diagonal there's
also this in the idea of playing 95 at
the right moment so what is deciding to
make sure that this situation is
clarified and now Queen to h1 very funny
move and I must sure I must share with
you the the name that I found in a in a
block for this the formation Reddy's
rifle like it now this is always one of
my my favorite configurations and chest
the Queen ER in the corner with the
bishop in front of it Randy's rifle ok
but when two rivals fires at each other
well they they won't survive so long so
look at the rifles that just traded and
93 now we've got another trade this is
however an endgame I think there were
white should have a very little
advantage and this is due to the pawn
islands blacks got three Pawn islands
though three and white only two and this
is a slight weakness on v6 so why it
should be somewhat better but somewhat
later too
cough played a very radical move and
this fairly typical of his style is not
the kind of person who sits and waits he
now played the move a five a big
breakthrough on the queenside which led
to a crisis around the b6 born yeah in
fact black Connecticut quite often and
after Luke a two yeah this make sense
rugby too is really not doing anything
with black pushing the a pond after rook
a to black just took it this is
basically an exchange sacrifice after a
to be too yeah he black he could have
played a form but this is probably also
leading just to it wrong so it took only
three which led to position with white
having an extra exchange an extra
exchange and black has got two pawns and
he's got an apron dangerous porn always
supported by the bishop and he has got
the H porn potentially um so very far
apart those two passes it seems that
after a couple of moves exactly in this
position here black had a very strong
rules pointed out by Dutch Grand Master
Irvin now me on Twitter and he posted
that doesn't a three-win he he said if
I'm not mistaken he believed it wins but
he wasn't one hundred percent certain
which I understand really I only had
limited time today so I couldn't really
come to a conclusion if it wins but it
seems to be an exceptionally dangerous
the point is that in a position like
that black has the idea to play efore
for example if he tries to to stop the a
pawn some black will play a form f king
e5 and he intends to pick up this pawn
or pick up d3 this can very quickly lead
to problems for wide for example if it
takes the
takes here there's the h-bomb running
this is already not stoppable anymore so
maybe you need to go here to try to stop
it yeah I go King before and it can
again be be really really quick white
losing like this oops and again the
h-bond runs and it is very tricky I
cannot really in this summary video post
one what I had what I was able to to to
analyze it wasn't that much I admit that
I couldn't really come to a conclusion
but i think my my gut feeling is black
should win this but i couldn't really
wrap it up completely with concrete
analysis um okay i can plate in the move
Bishop to f2 and after Luke h8 it
somehow turned out to be a position
where the rook is always guarding the H
born and the king is always guarding the
aprons and black is not able to make any
progress he cannot cannot reach this
type of activity with e for anymore that
was shown in the other line so after a
couple of moves they played like that
and now agree to a draw because there's
simply nothing to do black cannot
improve what cannot improve so a draw sm
completely logical um lets them to wrap
this up take a quick look at at the
tournament standings okay so here's them
cross-table taken from the weekend chess
good online chess magazine let's see on
7 points at one point of aronian plus
the better tie break so Aronian action
needs to overtake anand to to get the
qualification and followed by maariv
Krakens video and fifty percent so it's
one and a half points basically for all
of them and they're just three games
left Anand has three games left and I
can tell you where the opponent's he's
playing and draken with white which
seems like a game that he shouldn't lose
really maybe press a bit but don't get
crazy and then he's playing coyoacán
with black this is obviously a very
important game and he's playing white
and the final round against villa so the
only scenario really to be a halfway
realistic to see was she not qualifying
is that he loses to kayak eNOS Villa
being that this would lead to have him
having having a worse tiebreak losing to
one of those two guys and the other ones
just winning another game so let's say
honored Ross again son Drake any losses
against coyoacán place a draw again
against witla and kayaking wins another
game then then the qualification spot
wouldn't go to Ireland is still possible
it's not like he's already already
through however it can end really really
quickly if in the next round he's got
Dwight against and raking if i'm not
mistaken i think this is the the first
game of the three um if he wins that
that's that basically then then it's
basically over no way that they would
catch him then so am I personally would
estimate on insurances to qualify them
at about ninety percent at this moment
and to be perfectly honest it would have
been a very very deserved qualification
is the only player not having lost the
game all other players have lost two
games at least and this is really a big
difference one point and one and a half
points is quite a lot but okay they're
still games to be played and if Arnold
loses one game it will get very very
tense quickly this is quite clear but
the other the other players simply don't
win enough games I mean
and today for Ross I mean this is just
just not looking like it to be honest um
ok so let's see what what happens
tomorrow I'll be covering this round as
well of course thanks for watching